Martha Welsh 1971 College of Physicians
and Surgeons Columbia changed my life
even before medical school started I
first started thinking about premature
infants when I was doing my summer
research just prior to starting medical
school that was formative I have been
keenly aware of how wonderful it is to
be allowed to do research and I always
say that this could not have happened it
from any other school pns encouraged
creativity thinking outside the box and
that's what I've done and it's come to
fruition pns also has been very
important for my family my son I was
sort of set on going to pianist because
I took him to alumni reunion starting at
age one my son graduated from Columbia
College in 2003 he graduated from
pianist and 2008 and this month he's
graduating from pediatric residency
right here at Columbia in the mid 70s I
began attending alumni reunions on a
regular basis it was listening to the
research presented in those sessions
that made me think that I should be
doing research on the mechanisms I was
formulating about child development and
about mother infant interaction I was in
private practice and you just don't make
a leap into research from private
practice however we had a visionary Dean
of alumni relations and development
aankhen
she had the idea that I could be brought
on to the faculty to do the research
that would help prove the importance of
nurture so here I'm working on premature
infants just as I was that summer before
medical school right here at Columbia